okay four people joining this holiday
period live stream we are talking about
incremental language development for one
language and we have a variety of topics
data set options documentation review
yes we have have Chris with us and we
have looked at this before but we wanted
you to have a friend and look at their
pages but we've looked at these before
right yes yes we have it is the the
phrasing of the notes and things like
that
is a mega page well I understand ok data
set option so this is a new this is all
a new section by the way you've got a
lot of background noise again Jose I
don't know what this is um I'd be good
to get somebody to help you debug that
um yeah there's the new options section
and then under options below each of the
options has a section how similarly how
summarizes to the grid documentation
very similar I mean it's essentially
copied on from the grid documentation
and updated where necessary you know
what I trust you to do this I I'm not
gonna read all of this stuff I I think
you know you've done enough of these in
the past almost doesn't look obviously
silly okay um
Jose has had a look at it - yes through
these things
oops um now I mean things like you know
header alignment um you know obviously
there are other places where we could be
using that what else - where else do we
have header type stuff table view of
it's the only one I can think of and how
much of all of this stuff that we put in
today's set should be essentially port
to table view well I mean table view is
intended to be a lightweight control
like thing we don't want to load it down
not to control it was a version one
formatting function version one I think
so I just take a look I'm pretty sure it
was not tape no table form table form
yeah
version one there you go
right right I was thinking the table do
you I uh I said table for you by mistake
but my question here we've got things
like table headings here um right which
is specifying the headings and I just
wonder whether we should kind of update
table form after 30 years to use you
know to be essentially a print form that
applies data set like capabilities I
mean table form is a pure print form
right I think that's worth looking at
I'm basically using I mean thank
goodness we defensively named the
options here I think we should look at
doing that you know leveraging what
you've done with data set to let us
enhance table form okay I'll look into
that
what is hidden items that's the
programmatic way of specifying what you
can hide interactively did we approve
that name I believe so it's my is it
like a buried treasure type story or
something we did have a different name
and you changed to hidden items
that's a hidden item right the seashell
the seashore sound well very um I really
think this is debuggable Jose but mm you
didn't know
well now there's no seashore sound I was
muted - well now I think Jose is at the
seashore and there's some alright
there's a there's a definite course to
this maybe I'm anyway okay
yeah well this is fun we got this
background Seashore noise again um I
don't think that option is gonna be
particularly useful because it's really
more of an air active thing but it's
there hmm I don't know okay this
background noise is just driving me nuts
so I'm not hearing any any background
noise
yeah at first I think it's you not
hearing either I'm hearing well I'm not
hearing it now so so I'm going to mute
and tell me if it goes away
there's no no such background noise
right now now I am you didn't its back
well I'm in a very quiet environment I
understand that it's something that
microphone gain and I don't understand
what it is and we've seen this before
and we should ask suss it men what it is
okay I'm trying to get a debugged I'm
Devin maybe you could take
responsibility for doing that so that we
yes just just let's learn what it is and
that way we can tell people that it's
something to do with the gain set for
the you know I don't know what okay yeah
I'll pass it on okay the construction
and grid and related constructs
where is that used you known for example
like item style I think alright I think
I that data set is such a cool function
that which boy come first in that list I
could say data set grid and related
constructs a that make sense
okay okay
guide page knitting
place Korean functional programming
curried operator forms near the end okay
so these new functions did we knit them
at all I think Jose gab booted from I
don't believe I'm needed for the rest
this meeting is that right that is
correct okay well good thanks a lot hi
thank you Chris
is my sound but I know it is okay right
I solution but right okay yes so this is
a bit of knitting we wanted to do um we
have their new applied functions in some
pitches but we went okay whether to have
it in more places
remind me what all those functions are
well where's the page where we have them
we probably have a functional
programming page right yes and we added
them to the operators page not insulin
yet not at all on this one I think we
had Kerry at the end and we have to
replace it by one of the new operators
or perhaps both Kerry applies an
operator right okay so where where do we
at the end
okay so this is the page where we put
these functions into it yes we've got
the seashell thrower back again um okay
so it's operator applied re applied
reverse applied
I think we should add that as a line
here
um
how should we say this make a function
into an operator applied form
it's really weird I think we can just
say operator phone we use it a minority
of operator for many places
okay then we should put all right you
think we want to just turn this list
should we just put reverse applied and
all right let's say reverse applied
curry applied and then the others I
think that's reasonable I didn't think
we need to reverse implies they're
actually we're supplied is not an
operator form which sorry it's a
function to get supplied to arguments
but not it's not curried yes where does
it go on this page it's definitely a
functional programming story what a
subset map hmm if we put subset cases
and subset replaces have they all been a
subset map should it be
position
you
you
by the way where is where a star Adam at
and all those kind of over here we go
and wise right composition not here
you
you
you
some composition is more important than
great composition yeah what happens is
they're all right maybe we can put after
composition we could put Reverse applied
before operate I don't know why
distribute is even relevant here do you
understand that
ok ok let's go back then um let's see
it's just these three functions were
dealing with right yes and I assume that
reverse applied got linked to reverse
what's reversed oh that's it all name
yes that should be it
weebo do a search for that some I don't
think this is
because I think it's gonna find a bunch
other junk he's a menace
well okay but it didn't find oh I see we
not need to look for function pages as
well ah reference pages 121 results so
it's too many we have to do something
else yeah Oh
Sandra's pointing out our livestream
that slash star and at star are not
found by documentation search that
should be fixed that's an issue for the
search people Devon that would be for
you yes got it
um wow it's interesting question why can
data set be exported as a CSV Matt not
an XLS file I am very surprised by that
claim but that should be looked into
that's a question I suppose for Chris
okay is there anything else that needs
to be I assume that construct I mean
this is this seems like the right page
for these functions to be on like
operator applied and so on the only is
there anything
there's no like Matthew page that the
stuff should go on our predecessor I
think these two pages are enough okay so
then we need to place the subset Maps a
subset functions okay and there are
there are suggestions they are in the
agenda
have they been cross-linked to function
pages like sequence well these are the
old ones
so we're talking about Tony's functions
which I know I understand I understand I
had forgotten sequence fold
what a sequence fault - again it's able
to take more arguments than just to
write
I bet the places I could have used that
humph okay all right let's go to these
pages
by the way I've asked this about eight
times but how we get the search to not
go to this Devon maybe you could ask
that again please
okay yes that's the thing for Roger
okay let's open these various things up
and some lists operations on SATs if I
just start typing oh oh yes how nice
oh gosh
sequence alignment in comparison
again the diskette cross-linked did
subset replace and things get linked to
the other things that they should be
linked to I'm not sure Tony has been
working on these reference pages but one
extra
but fret not buckling okay so can you
take care of that yep okay all right
constructing lists
beyond the constructing lists page
well because it has a convenient Oriole
favor is one of their subsequences yeah
one of them there I mean arguably there
should be a page specifically about
sub-lists
operations operations on sublists right
yeah we have we have worked with a
number now
definitely goes here [ __ ]
oh my gosh testing set containment okay
so I reckon it goes in a section here
and it would be entitled something like
you
subset analysis operations on subsets
okay so then this would be so what we
have here are okay so we've got subset
cases subset replaced in subset position
what else do we have what do we have
others as well subset M subsets kind yes
nestled I think subset cases is
important and I think subsets replace is
important I think the others could be
listed
I think it's pretty obvious what the
other other ones do
yes I think in cases position and count
always go together I think subject
replaces worth separately calling out
maybe okay find
cases
um
subsets of elements will
matching a bit specified pattern
replace subsets of elements think that's
all we need to say that correct
okay okay now we've got elements of
lists
do you think we should put subsets map
on this line as well do you think that's
totally irrelevant it's kind of
redundant kind of works in a different
way
never mind I think it's relevant when we
get to subset replace we should probably
put subset map at the end of that list I
think um okay so you also proposed
elements of lists here
perhaps another list like their last one
but we're there it's nice it goes
finding sublists yeah so that's the
three sub list finding functions
perhaps no time no list
indicating that it's finding subsets and
that becomes just subset position that
sounds sensible all right let's look at
sequence alignment it gets much less
relevant here I think it's kind of
irrelevant to be honest here okay so we
have the same list yes position
specialist I know that because that's
sequences which is relevant for sequence
alignment um okay but I think we should
have another page about sub lists
basically operations on sub lists if you
can try and collect some things for that
let's try and write it
okay so
don't forget infinite past ninfa future
probably should be linked from infinity
and so on right yeah the the backlinks
aren't finished on all of those yet I
wasn't sure since they were marked as
experimental but if you want them
backlink I can do that should be
backlink even if it's experimental it
should be backlink okay where's data
interval garden on this page most of the
objects are towards the top we could
have a separate section dealing with
interval related things but since it's
most similar to date objects and time
object I'd probably put it up there yeah
maybe we should put a tail boy this page
is becoming complicated we might want to
break some pieces off here date interval
yeah we could always I was thinking we
could split it into representations of
dates and then operations on dates or
something like that yes probably yeah
getting pretty long
cause pretty off-track okay an object
representing an interval of time but a
first statement yeah okay now here we
probably need two infinite future
infinite passed him for the future right
yeah I wasn't sure if we want it to be
right below today tomorrow yesterday
since those are kind of similar and I
mean they're not they're not in the same
wheelhouse but it's a little closer to
those than the current date next date
maybe they're obscure though yeah
they're infinite past well and future
cost we gotta fix that stupid comma
thing I don't know how to do that um you
know what I'm talking about
okay so representations used for
did used for unbounded time intervals um
do we want to specifically include
interval a we you there are not very
many use cases but there are potential
cases like you know an end date for a
scheduled task maybe okay okay wait
representations for unbounded times or
something yeah that makes sense to me I
don't know Jose if you have a strong
opinion here it's time specification
okay all right so now where does min
date and next date go so it goes in here
yeah it's most closely related to date
bounds which is in the middle this page
needs to get broken up yeah yeah I'll
work on an outline for that for after
twelve one fine um earliest comma latest
times and add a tenth of all is that
right
yeah I mean the line above we say first
in last dates but earliest and latest
also it's synonymous there we may just
want to keep the language the same
either way you know what let's just put
these aligned listing they don't need to
be yeah it's pretty obvious what they
are unless people
but infinite past him to the future on
this same line I move them down from the
top what do you think did operations
alright okay that's those happy to me
okay don't forget to link min date Max
state to min max all that kind of stuff
I was gonna double-check do you I don't
think it necessarily makes sense but
there is an interval arithmetic page
that does refer to some interval
operations I don't know if it makes
sense to include a tuition well why
don't we boy don't we put some of that
in yeah why don't we put what that's
what where is the interval page
I think it's called interval arithmetic
pretty sparse at the moment why don't we
put him by the way why an earther
min/max not on here they work for it
don't they yeah and also we should point
interval if it doesn't already point it
around we should point it around that's
crazy yeah I know it's mentioned on the
guide page for a number D yeah should
I'm gonna be cross-linking to interval
anyway so I can add that in if you're
not already
well this page about intervals should um
this is a very old and Tufte guide page
that's for sure
that should be in there by the way there
isn't a date min/max as there I know
that's what date bounce does we could
have one but it no no let's not do that
yeah um okay so here all this stuff here
date date with in queue and so on all
goes here go ahead what we're gonna say
I was thinking that something that has
appeared a number of times is how do you
find the length of an interval and we do
the and with these via regions
functionality because intervals
understood as regions how do we how do
you find the length of an interval with
arc lengths that's crazy that's bonkers
that's just crazy we should have an
interval length function yes so on this
page we should also have the stuff about
regions then if this is so we should
have a section here called geometry of
intervals right
okay anyway for this we should have
by the way shouldn't we have infinity on
this page for intervals because you can
have that inside an interval right
[Music]
how do we want to describe that
how to describe it um
okay so here date with NQ is certainly
in that story what else is in that story
date bounds yeah date overlap skew also
and then probably men date in Mac state
if we are listing things nothing else
duration we can have on their duration
works on date intervals I don't know
that I mean that's again tied up with
wanting to have interval length also but
if because this because this hub it
doesn't specifically list it I was going
to add it when I add the backlinks and
well but here but let's put put it'll
just line here okay
okay let's plan a page for data
intervals okay a specific guy page for
them I think so date representation date
intervals date operations okay okay okay
now
true story what do we what can we do
that turn region turning interval into a
geometric region I'm not sure how far
the air analogy goes but some functions
certainly like our lynx support interval
our operations better check that okay
why don't you check that and let me know
oh that's terrible Sanders say he uses
in two lengths is first at star
differences that star min/max to get the
length of a duration sighs I saw um
works and and it supports the MU T
interval notation - okay what else works
be nice to have something here I mean
that's a very weird thing to be listing
here there must be other things like arc
length interval region region member Q
and things why don't you finish this and
link it to UM the relevant region stuff
okay okay question here on whether
there's a link from date/time to earth
position around the Sun that there is
there you can just ask for astronomical
data of that I think can't you yes yes
yes we can compute astronomical
coordinates in this case it would be of
the Sun so we have some position for
example yeah so if we say planet data of
Earth and then we say position actually
if we say
how do we ask for that will be
coordinate some type of coordinates
hello centric coordinates Helio
coordinates there you go
cool what is that was the origin was the
angular origin of those I guess this is
measured from the solar system body
center and oriented with ecliptic
doesn't have a clear freedom first point
of areas or something yeah it will be
the further on the vernal equinox so the
intersection between the quick ecliptic
and the equatorial planes years is
arguably given the Earth from the Sun is
so important it might be there might be
a better way to get this than than
having to ask that but the answer to
your question from the live stream is
those how to get it um okay all right
should we go on right whistles at that
section okay let's go to echo timing yes
so these we have these implement and Ian
implements this in the external if you
want to use it yes what is it so it
gives you timing it echos the timing of
a particular thing exactly and then you
know I'd love to be able to get code and
basically color-coded by how long how
much time was spent in that piece of
code
I see so that's profiling yes let me
just push the update to see yes okay
I'm pushing that update um okay
X kernel here we come
you
you
there's another question I lost
polic integration which is not the
subject of this meeting hopefully
somebody else could answer that
okay
you
all right so echo timing I'm I guess my
major confusion is what happens when
these nest and how do you know what's
going on so if I go here and I say pause
point five semicolon echo timing of that
okay okay okay okay I see I see so so as
it returns it says so these these time
elapsed s-- so if I were to do this if I
would say um
well so let me
ah okay so let me let me say I do this
let's say echo timing
hmm says a table
- JA - to the N I don't know how big can
these be anybody know great let's say
ten to fifty in steps of 10 okay and
then let's let go timing the whole thing
okay
we're not giving units here no following
the other I mean somebody is asking us a
little challenge here which is how would
you work out the position of Halley's
Comet and let's see whether we can do
that at a particular date so I assume
that this has a dated capability right
you probably but I'm not sure about the
annotation that should be made to work
that maybe another way to do this here
but this is that should definitely be
made to work
there's a date to qualifier there I
don't know whether you can ask for that
particular date we should check into
this this is something that should be
made to work you know so I don't know
what what this does with respect to how
the date qualifier works for this it
certainly should be able to work because
it's I mean whether whether one can
accurately compute it 2,000 years ago I
have no idea um so how do we feed in a
date attribute here we say this oops I
think it's a survivor meant probably
with it with just date yes that's not
promising I have to find that out okay
we should make that work and we should
make it work with dated yes yes
No
you
well that's interesting okay so that is
saying those are property modifiers on
um
yeah that's doing the right thing
okay let's ask this we have to ask this
position
oops love Halley's Comet on December 25
comma one ad if this manages to work
I'll be very impressed
okay
well it got the dates correct why it has
the right ascension declination I guess
that's what you want I guess I guess you
want the right Ascension and declination
yes that's just that way of expressing
yeah because that's the position right
so how do I get this in why is that not
a computer what oh I see that's a a data
set so if we say normal of that so how
do we how do we represent those if we
wanted to know um where these were in
the sky how do we work out where these
are in the sky to put a clear point on
the earth the horizontal coordinates in
order to form a gift from a given
position right okay so there's an
exercise to work out where this is I
don't know my Bible stories well enough
to know exactly where this should be
when that location indeed but then you
have to map that onto the rotation of
the earth and so awesome um and I have
no idea whether the orbit computation
for Halley's Comet works all the way
back there because I don't know whether
these I don't know whether the I would
think the solar wind acting on the you
know blowing ice off the you know
evaporating ice would have an effect
um anyway okay
see I'm now just curious about one thing
which is
so whether we can compute that distance
from Earth 32 astronomical units what is
it now for example
you
so like hundreds of astronomical units
now
hmm well something is unconvincing there
I don't know comment I thought I know
the answer but that this doesn't sound
obviously wrong no no I understand I
have no idea what the whole story is
okay let's go back to our topic here um
yeah so there are some questions here on
the left in the agenda so the first one
is that even though it says timing this
is actually absolute timing so that this
sounds like a good idea but I built the
repeat timing that's going to repeat it
timing is really going to make up a mess
of a lot of operations yes it will slow
it down and yes okay but my biggest
concern is how do you know what your
timing its first functioned kids know
it's kind of when it rough when it echos
normally in echo you have the ability to
give if I say echo
right so if I say
you
you
you
how do I give
she went off a label or the expression
that was timed no I I want to have a
label um but in echo the way I give a
label as I literally say echo X label
right right and the problem of that is
that the very beautiful just insert echo
at which is what you typically want to
do this type of thing
see my question is okay and this relates
to okay I have a question if I say
dynamic of stack does it do anything
halfway reasonable here so if I run this
happen too quickly let's go up a bit
higher um
you
no it doesn't respond I look at that
dynamic doesn't respond there possibly
because it's looking at the wrong kernel
okay so in this example it's kind of
useless because I don't know which one
is which
I mean in Echo see the problem is with
echo timing you're not echoing the
expression that got generated you're
just echoing the timing but now if you
want it to echo the expression that the
timing of an expression you could say
echo I mean so the difference is echo
function so this is equivalent to echo
function of timing of this is it not or
absolute timing not really that is this
is the last note in the agenda so there
is an issue here with holding so echo is
not hold function but we can't eat
unevaluated expressions so timing will
receive they already evaluated
expression so it's too late in life
that's why we have to have an echo
timing yes well we could do it as it's
written on the left with echo an
evaluative expression the problem there
is that the expression gets evaluated
twice and that's the thing we want less
disastrous yeah okay so in eco timing we
are taking advantage of the fact that we
know that timing and a short timing both
return the result anything so we have to
really okay I don't see the point of
having time elapsed there and it isn't
even elapsed either because it's not
it's not elapsed it's the time of a
particular thing and if we're gonna say
it I think we should say timing because
that's what it is but I would argue that
we should just have a different icon
maybe a little clock thingy maybe a
little clock clock before the greater
than greater than or we could have a
label argument and then just a different
color always an icon missing
I would like to try an icon I mean
either either a clock before the greater
than greater than or a single greater
than an o'clock there or something like
that um it's possible to have the same
color scheme but then although I I kind
of like the fact okay so one frustrating
thing is that the only way to collect
things that have been echoed is to
copy-paste them basically but I think by
the time where we're having echo
collectors and quiet echo
the problem is this feels an awful lot
like kind of you know holds and quotes
and so on but by the way I figured out
one thing you remember we were talking
about recursive function evaluation and
combinators an innermost and outermost
and so on I did realize that hold is the
way that we control the difference
between in a most and outermost
evaluation at least for a single level
okay off topic topic um
okay so one issue is you don't know what
it was an echo from
I mean for example with echo timing
you're not giving any echo results so to
speak so there's a certain argument that
what you should do is is there a page
for echo timing okay there's a certain
argument that what you should be able to
do okay so the the most obvious thing is
just echo timing of X bar okay and the
question is what else do you get beyond
that and I would say that there's an
argument that you could say
well the Bekaa be a function here
that is what you apply to the results of
the evaluation to echo here
see what I'm saying and that the default
would be somehow none which would
basically produce no echo of the result
of the evaluation and then a third
argument would be and we were stacking
this up with arguments but there's the
label and there's also the question of
which kind of timing it is what about
having a tilted width of the expression
that got evaluated it could be very big
yes that's Jo I need to be nice to have
a function that you can run well okay so
the automatic case
okay we could have an option to this
thing I mean
how would you do this the basic point is
you can't do this with echo itself
because of the double evaluation is you
right you can't do an echo function
right second function
echo supports unevaluated expressions
and then it can be done but it evaluates
twice function could be made to support
that too but it would suffer from the
same problem
I don't think it's a good idea okay so
the issue is the other the other issue
that we have is is it absolute timing
versus CPU time and I have to say I
would imagine that there could be other
variants of that like for example when
there are parallel sub kernels what is
it I mean the question of what timing
really measures is a complicated
question that we should return to does
it measure multiple threads if it's if
it's running on multiple threads how
does that work
so I'm saying yep so I personally think
that we should we should probably return
to the function timing and think about
giving it second arguments that specify
different kinds of timing like thread
totals etc so those are possibilities
that already exists in timing itself oh
I know I know I know I know that I'm
simply saying that that right now as we
design echo timing it's just gonna call
absolute timing and it's not going to
make any commentary about that but in
the future I'm saying that timing should
allow many variants of different timing
with respect to multiple threads and so
on
um okay so sander is pointing out that
that we should put the label
well I mean
yeah I have a label I'm not sure
grieveth that i mean that the the issue
is
you
you
this is not
what it prints this is what it prints is
the time
um where would we put it here you know
when we put it as part of the label what
was evaluated where would we put that we
put it in parentheses after the number
well we put it what what are you trained
to put whatever it is that we say is the
whatever the thing is the return from
this function that is the thing that
annotates the elapsed took that the
timing to get what I'm saying that the
the thing that in the default case
there'd be nothing there but in the non
default case it might be I don't see why
we need the result in any case it would
be the input the result is just a sort
of no no the result of the echo timing
is a time no result of echo timing is
the evaluation of expression exactly
it just I understand I understand that
point okay so your point is your claim
would be if you really want the behavior
that I'm describing then just do this
that's pretty reasonable actually right
that's a pretty reasonable way to do it
okay so I'm I'm taking back what I said
I mean we were obviously document that
case that looks really nice actually um
okay so that means there's no reason to
put any of that junk in the timing
because you can always label the thing
by whatever comes after it and it will
be exactly after it if you echo the echo
timing right having an arbitrary label
rather than always time elapsed
oh no no we don't want that we don't
want look we want just a little clock
symbol here now I mean if I do it the
other way around actually let me just do
this in real life
okay let me do a code timing of echo of
that yeah that's really pretty nice
little bit why because it could take
take something oh that I'm not worried
about that yeah um alright then that
means that the argument if there is an
argument to echo timing
I would for the time being defensively
put in a method option to decide whether
it's absolute timing or timing and so on
because I think we might want to use the
arguments of echo timing for something
else so I would put in a method option
for that okay and let's get an icon
designed recognizing that this will be a
common case that we want to have you
know this echo together with echo timing
will be a common case
so is it just going to be a clock icon
with no text and no : no text let's do
one the : no okay I want something like
this I don't know what it should be I
mean maybe I like the fact that this is
a greater than greater than that but III
don't know we need some different design
or I mean possibly it's a clock super
impotent the greater than great amounts
superimposed on it I'm not sure possibly
there's another color involved I'm not
sure
you
this is arguably crazy is it crazy or is
this not crazy I must admit I used the
equivalent block echo quite a lot
because sometimes have many echoes and I
would have them yeah
but perhaps what we need to do is to is
to yeah well the other possibilities to
extend quiet to deal with echo
why does quiet not switch off echo
because it's not a message this doesn't
work through the message framework but
quiet could independently switch off
echo
we could extend it we could put we
couldn't meet echo in the second
argument for example that's bad yeah why
don't we ask his who deals with quiet
right now is it Danny or somebody else
himself yeah well I can't I was muted
because of quiet of course it was it was
David libera that did that I think but
it's based on some internal
functionality I guess it could be me I
don't remember the code very well let's
let's analyze the possibility that quiet
does this okay and has some collection
of additional I mean as we work towards
this exception handling mechanism where
we're going to have named messages and
so on
I mean quiet is going to have to get
more sophisticated I mean banks of
messages which we switch on and off to
represent exceptions and so on quiet
will get more sophisticated I don't
think having quiet switch off echo is
the Zoe idea right now I don't see any I
mean I I think those are independent
issues and I'm trying to think do you
want something where you switch off echo
but you get messages yes you might think
it was a very debugging typically thing
and sometimes you want it the standard
behavior but without the I agree I mean
okay so okay what's on the table is a
quiet echo is that even the right name
for it problem with quiet echo is it
sounds like it is a no it's it's an echo
of a quiet type that's where I would
think silent echo no because do you know
what this is for well
since I've never used echo it's not
entirely clear it's to make echo not
print or maybe silent is the wrong word
but it is the wrong word block given
that or tally has something internally
similar called disable honestly block
echo doesn't sound I mean that's very
similar to a lot of our other blocking
functions
there's the confusion as to what the
block means even with our block
construct actually but it's inevitable
there yeah it sounds like look random
yeah there's an intentional ambiguity
it's not intentional but it's there and
it's okay
with block echo I'm not sure that that
would be such a good thing that end I
kind of agree yeah I see your point
because block fun don't we still have
from them this inside yeah yeah it's
still a block of code and it's still
blocking random in a sense
well at least we could have a function
repository function for doing this which
you just wrote here basically but I
think we should have some system thing
I'm not sure that that name is right
okay we're gonna have to wrap up here
but I just want to point out this is one
of many stupid annoying things that come
out of number form another stupid
annoying thing is
you know when you have a big collection
of numbers it's 4.5 5.0
you can't get the thing to not print the
points after the five point so if you
want label up lots with four point five
five five point five six how do you do
that without those points
other than this number fine ghost which
is a total hack I mean that's a really
common thing to want to do it's the sort
of most elementary way of labeling a
plot the fact you're living at five
point is some kind of internal
implementation issue not relevant to the
presentation of the plot
right so the only thing I can think here
is this number one goes to none because
it cannot be string string is
immediately assumed to be their point I
understand but we shown to be none then
we don't want you to always want it to
be none we want something we're on four
point five prints this four point five
but 5.0 princess five that's the point I
mean and you know we want something
where I don't know where the number form
does this I mean if I say number form
you
no that's just completely stupid I would
like that to printer's 5.00
what um are you sure that that three is
not supposed to be something in friends
with with another argument well it could
be but that's that's precision yeah I
mean that forces that okay but that's
pretty obscure okay so the main point is
I don't think we can change the default
behavior of the single number second
argument no no we can't but so we'll
need some new function that does this
because we need a way to do this because
I need this every time I make a plot
that has four point five and five on it
I don't want five point on there
don't know what the name of the could we
could we inventory why this is happening
right so I mean the thing is to get
consistent things four point five five
point zero four point five five with no
point anything etc makes sense
arguably makes sense but I don't think
that that lives in any of the functions
we have correct it probably doesn't it's
probably a new function well it it's
well hidden in decimal form
maybe yes I understand but it probably
isn't not sorry not just before in
percent form oh that's ridiculous
right that's ridiculous look it is
ridiculous about it no no it's a thing
you want whenever you make a plot that
has those kinds of numbers in it right
it should be the defaults basically for
tick labeling for numbers and it's
completely stupid and annoying that it
isn't check label form no it's not just
that can we can we figure out what the
semantics of the thing should be and
then we work out its name okay no wait a
second
what it is is don't put the decimal
point when you don't need it
I know and because you insisted on that
in percent form we have the semantics in
there but I don't think they're exposed
in any other of these formatting
functions perhaps we need that number
pointless automatic else not a bad idea
yeah that's a possibility um yeah that's
a good idea I like that and that becomes
then potentially the default for these
tip labels
those would be something to discuss
respect yeah why don't you look into a
number point goes to automatic I think
that's a very good idea um okay this is
a possible clock icon something like
that I agree it to lap 1 is a little bit
light um and apparently there's a
unicode character how do we type in
backslash : is that right and then I
type
on earth
five five
ah I didn't work what is the way of
typing a four byte unicode character do
you remember it's a new piece of
functionality
yes it's good that our system is
segmented with pieces that not all of us
know about um I forgot now you do this
yeah it's it there's a way of typing a
four byte unicode character um
you
you
okay by the way for folks on this
livestream a reminder that we have our
answer this even works but I don't think
this will work um
oh it does work as a clock um okay
reminder that we have our part two of
our suggestions and priorities in about
30 minutes um all right hey I really
like this number a number point goes to
automatic this is really good um
Devlin if you're on you can assign that
one to me all right
okay and then we need to talk to Brett
about putting that in by default that
will be a great thing for 12.2 okay very
good thanks all and nothing else
okay see you after the holiday